you know there's a tradition you've
probably heard of it called dry january
that's where a lot of people abstain
from drinking alcohol for all
of january and uh andy
this is something you'd like to do is
that right yeah
i mean it's it's nice to hit the reset
button after the holidays and just kind
of
you know clean yourself out yeah so tell
me uh
how's your dry january going so far
well uh if you'll refer to the calendar
here um it started off
strong um i got through january 5th
with no problems but then there was uh
an attempted coup and i spent the day
glued to the news so i
i made an exception on that day and had
a drink
you know andy i'm going to say that
that's very understandable
a lot of us were stressed out that day
so i wouldn't be too hard on yourself
well yeah then a couple days later los
angeles announced that we're at
150 icu capacity because of the covert
surge
so i made another exception and i had a
drink
wow andy that was a rough time too
and then kim cattrall announced she's
not coming back for the sex and the city
reunion so of course
that was a drinking day not
sure that's a reason to start and then i
read that kim and kanye
are getting divorced so i had to have a
drink and then i read they're not
getting divorced so i had a drink for
that too
then i went to trader joe's and they
were all out of jingle jangle and they
won't be getting any more for 11 months
because it's a seasonal item
i mean if that's not cause for a drink i
don't know what is
andy what happened on the 12th
well i smudged my sad face so you know i
needed a drink
and between that and finding out wonder
woman 1984 is a little underwhelming
and my postmates delivery not including
a side of thousand island
like i specifically requested i mean how
the hell is anyone expected to stay
sober around here okay well andy i
i don't like to say this but it sounds
like you're drinking the same
as any other month possibly even more
how dare you judge me this is an abusive
workplace
i'm making an exception this sketch was
brought to you by
alcohol it's all we have okay
you